Gert Wilder's far right anti Islam party has won
the most seats in the Dutch parliamentary elections.
Here's why you should be seriously worried.
The Party for freedom or PVP
won 37 out of 150 seats,
well ahead of any of its rivals.
Now they get the first shot at forming a government
by starting coalition talks of other parties.
If they manage to form a coalition
to take a majority in parliament,
then it is likely that wielders will be appointed prime
minister. So far
the Green Labour left wing Bloc has ruled out this idea
due to wielders extreme policies,
but other parties
such as the centrist and a SEA party
are considering it.
Wielders main policies include a ban on Islamic schools,
Qurans, mosques
and headscarfs,
a referendum to leave the EU,
closing the borders to immigrants,
asylum seeking refugees,
deporting all undocumented immigrants
and ending all support to Ukraine.
Rise of good
Wilders is a very warring sign for things to come.
He's run on the platform of blaming Muslims and
immigrants for most of the problems in the Netherlands,
despite the making up less than 5% of the population.
And he used dangerous language to describe them
such as Scrib
Moroccans in the Netherlands a scum
and comparing Muslims to Nazis.
There are many legitimate fears now
4 minorities in the Netherlands
and the rest of Europe
where it has become mainstream to be
racist towards Muslims and immigrants.
It also affects a huge double Standard in Europe,
where anti Semitism is of rightly intolerable,
but anti Muslim incitement is not just tolerated
but normalized.
For those who still think that being anti
Muslim is justified,
it is important to look back in history
as to where fascism and mass atrosity start.
It doesn't happen suddenly,
but begins with the demonization
and persecution of a particular group.
When a country suffers internally,
politicians often resort to the easy thing
and blame the outsiders for their problems.
History tells us that these divisive
and hateful tactics will only bring
terrible consequences for society,
yet we never seem to learn.